so about 10 to 14 times a week I get an
email or somebody stops me in the street
literally and say Gary you always talk
about working so much the hustle all the
hours you need to put in well hey man I
know working hard is great but I work
smart that's why I'm gonna win just as
much and I always say to them why not
both why not working smart all the time
and hustling because the people that
really crush are doing that you know
you're working smart end hard why not
both a couple days ago I started talking
about the fact that I'm tripling down on
content and there was a Forbes article
written about this whole situation now I
got a little bit taken out of hand of
like somebody followed me around
literally 24 hours a day I wish it was
that cool Steve you know you don't have
to follow me 24 hours a day you go with
that but the fact of the matter is I am
simply down on contact and that's
because the reason I have to work with
somebody like awesome Steve over here is
because I'm not good at running down my
thoughts or recording my thoughts and so
getting a call at the end of the day and
recapping was there any good content is
really important thing to me I do think
content is a barrier of entry I'm Scott
Monty wrote a great piece on his blog
kind of talking about this idea of me
having 24 hours a day like how this was
terrible he's right I think I did a poor
job communicating to Dorian Forbes about
what I was actually doing but that's not
the interesting thing that's not why I'm
making a video I'm making a video of why
not both why not work hard and smart
equaling huge results and why not if you
look at Scott's blog post which is
really smart where he says wait a minute
this is the worst thing ever I love Gary
but this is a bad idea because what the
world definitely doesn't need is more
content
what we need is quality not quantity he
is 100 percent right but there's two
problems number one nobody's gonna care
here's what I mean quantity is coming my
friends last year 380 billion pictures
were taken and that is 10 percent of all
the pictures taken ever think about that
for a second so what the piece coming
whether Scott or I or anybody else that
more importantly who's the definer of
quality for example I don't want any
videos I hate cats that's right you
heard it I dislike them not into them
though the internet loves cats and so we
all have different views of what quality
is but that's not even the conversation
the conversation is this I am devastated
that so many things that I've wanted to
communicate to my community or things
that I wanted to interact with pass in
my head and escape at the end of day I'm
devastated that one of the people by the
way here's a little side note the
conversation you go to Scott Monty's
blog which I'll link up right here
between me CC Chapman and Scott Monty
shows the real power of Twitter and
really is a whole nother video in itself
which is we need to start respecting and
communicating with each other instead of
just flaming it out I mean the
conversation there really recaps why I
think Twitter is incredible but being a
little less a teeny jumping back into my
point why not both quality and quantity
nobody would complain if Michael Jordan
I hate him with all my heart nobody
would have complained if he played
another a couple of seasons in his prime
nobody would have complained if the
Beatles put out a couple more albums I
think there's a really healthy debate of
why not both quality and quantity the
quality is gonna happen but there's a
ton a ton of quality being left every
day because of unorganized people like
myself that just let it go by don't
write it down don't record it once you
feel it and I have putting the
infrastructure around those kind of
organizations and people it's gonna be
an interesting debate and I do think
that that's what's gonna happen so I'd
love to see your thoughts on this I
think it's a I think it's a really
interesting time for content the there
definitely is way too much crap but I do
think that a lot of people are leaving
greatness on the table